and finally new rule if Donald Trump is
looking for a legacy don't buy Greenland
save Greenland that should be your
legacy mr. president and I'll tell you
something else if you get religion on
global warming and become the greatest
echo warrior we've ever had in politics
I'll vote for you I tweeted that last
week I guess some people thought I was
kidding I'm not I don't know if you are
following the news about the environment
but it is definitely at the last chance
whatever it takes
moment and I know the president is
hearing me because last week he tweeted
this saying he saw the show by accident
[Laughter]
he said the same thing a couple of years
ago how do you watch an HBO show for an
hour by accident when it was over did
you say hey that wasn't ballers boy that
Bill Maher looks just like the rock
but but look I'm glad we're talking sir
at one of your recent rallies you called
me a serious person and I appreciate
that you also called me third-rate and a
so-called comedian and then a respective
comedian I guess I'm complicated you
also said I was wacky which isn't really
that big an insult for a comedian
side-splitting comedian Bill Maher but
look I'm not here to fight I'm here to
offer my vote and so mr. president your
excellency
least racist person in the world let me
address you directly and try to win you
over with logic because I know flattery
simply will not work you're impervious
to it bounces off you like bullets from
Superman's chest so I I'm not even gonna
try that not on a man as great as you
I'm not that wacky I'd look foolish
trying and you would see through it
right away because you're a stable
genius and did I mention handsome when I
see you and Melania together I always
think which one was the model
but sir picture this headline trump
saves earth feels right doesn't and all
that would take is for you to undergo a
sudden profound change like the Grinch
when he saved Christmas
how befitting a man of such power of
such great intellect and large
completely unlike penis
[Applause]
someone who has the most beautiful words
and a slavish devotion to the truth I
bet if you do this the people will put
your face on the hundred dollar bill
combining your two great loves money and
you and then I think they will put you
on Mount Rushmore that'd be a switch huh
someone chiseling you no I was kidding
I'm sorry please mr. president before
you change the channel and go back to
your chess game look I know I know we've
tangled in the past
[Applause]
you you sued me once and and we both
have said some things and you called me
stupid not considered smart a dummy not
a smart guy the dumbest man on
television fired like a dog very sad
pathetic bloated and gone
dumbass a rather dumb guy a lowlife
dummy don't be dumb as a rock [ __ ]
stupid guy a very dumb guy failing
comedian and most hurtful of all rosie
is smart
and I called you a whiny little [ __ ]
but I'm just going to admit it right now
I was jealous I was always have been I
mean who's kidding who we both know you
have the best brain and everything you
take on is an incredible success you won
the trade war you built the wall you
effortlessly solved the Middle East and
stormy Daniels is still basking in the
afterglow of your incredible lovely
[Applause]
women want to be with you and men want
to be like you I know I do in fact as a
tribute to you I've taken to wearing
I'll show you
toilet paper on my shoe
and I'm sure many would follow if you
embrace the environment think about the
a-listers who overnight would become
your biggest fans
Brad Matt Clooney the White House would
be like Ocean's eleven Taylor Swift will
be begging to follow you on twitter
DiCaprio will love you
Giselle will love you Ivanka will get
invited to parties again you'll be a big
hero in her eyes and we know you love
her in a completely appropriate way look
sir you're already the greatest
president ever that's a fact because
people are saying it
so I can see why you might be thinking
why do I need to Gilda Lily I've already
saved mankind from extinction once after
Obama do I have to do it twice yes sir
I'm afraid you do please sir
lend your giant brain to work with the
other lesser brains in the scientific
community and if you save the planet
billions of children will be grateful
and one of them could be your next wife
[Applause]
so please remember my pledge become a
pitbull for planet Earth and you won't
need Russia to hack my polling place I
will vote for you I will take my paper
ballot and put my prick next to your
face
you